he's Mike Florio from Pro Football Talk
Pro Football Talk live as their a
co-host hi Mike hey that was you in the
gym sorry I'm sorry to call you out
there Mike seriously how much can you
bench Mike oh god I have no idea those
days are long long behind me
best ever best ever two-twenty okay
maybe I don't know when yeah I'd say 220
was that one rep when I got to the point
now I could do a couple but I never I
never felt confident putting any more on
the bar I was always afraid I was gonna
crush my chest you know you have this
stuff going on at the combine and you
know we we it's paralysis by analysis
and now it's hand sight first it was
Kyler Murray's height now it's his hand
size here like they're gonna they're
gonna work to find something that is
gonna convince somebody not to draft him
here what's more important how tall he
is or how big his hands are I think the
hand size is a bigger issue Dan because
look you bought from that college
football to the NFL ball and there is a
fundamental difference you try to grip a
college ball it's easier to grip than an
NFL ball and if there is an issue with
hand size that's how it manifests itself
you see a lot of fumbles murmurs Dante
Culpepper six five to six to be had
small hands had a ton of fumbles so from
the standpoint of being able to throw
the ball to being able to hold on to the
ball I think it's far more important I
joked earlier today that height and
weight issues with Tyler Maria did a
convenient distraction from the
possibility that his hands aren't big
enough that's really the metric that
matters are you all in on Kyler Murray
you still got a question mark there I'm
fascinated by what he could be I'm
concerned because when I
he weighs 205 it's like is he swallowing
bricks like I don't I yeah you know you
saw him at the week of the Super Bowl we
had Russell Wilson and we had caller
Murray a couple of hours later and
there's a fundamental difference between
Wilson and Murray from a bulk standpoint
you Murray isn't just sure he's like
sleight of Freimuth if you start packing
extra muscle on that sternum where is it
all going to go I mean eventually he's
going to be like more compact and Popeye
and at some point you lose some of your
explosiveness if you put too much weight
on so
that's what I'm concerned about this is
overall frame not necessarily how tall
he is
and I also worry about this baseball
angle dad and he's saying all the right
things but there has to be a spot
between 1 and 256 we're below that spot
all of a sudden baseball sounds better
to him again and he did say he's all-in
with football for now if he's a top
tight sure talk to it came sure at what
point after 15 at what point after 20 at
what time after round 1 is the point
where he says and you know Oakland A's
I had another change of heart I'll take
your money again now I don't expect him
to fall that far because last year he
has five first five quarterbacks and
they all worked out and I think
quarterbacks are going to get over
drafted this year and Marie's got that
sizzle factor and the big upside but
that's my concern that they're slowly in
a sweet spot that ends up not being very
sweet if they draft him and he decides
well you know what I was wrong about all
of this I'm going to play baseball at
start who's more employable Antonio
Brown and maybe on bail just 27 last
week and he had a full year off which
means Lunger was no wear and tear of any
time and I think the market for running
backs you get him dollar for dollar
cheaper you can employ him as a past
catcher at one point he was justifying
his contract demands from the Steelers
by saying he's a number one tailback in
a number two receiver so I would want
lady on table for it morning - Tony
O'Brien also game to get lady on bail
without having to give anything up and
that's the biggest impediment to trading
Antonio Brown because you have to make
the Steelers happy with compensation to
them you have to make brown happy he's
made it clear he wants a contract too so
whatever you have to give up by way of
drastic compensation that's less money
you're gonna want to get brown with bail
you can just blow it out Tim what he
wants and you've got a guy who can be
you know three down running back who
really helps revolutionize your offense
do you agree with the report that the
Steelers wouldn't send him to the
Patriots or another team in the AFC
North is that is that smart business on
their part witness funny that that's
coming out the same time their GM
admitted that only three teams of
contact them about brown which means 28
teams aren't interested like
are you applying these grandiose
standards to what you want for brown
when ten percent of the league is
willing to trade forms and if it's the
carpals of the forty niners offering a
fifth round kick but the Patriots or the
Browns or the Ravens or the Bengals say
we'll send you a to how do you turn your
nose up at that we saw Donna McNabb get
traded in the division we've seen
Bledsoe get traded in the division by
the Patriots to the bills I think it all
comes down to what you're getting in
return and I can't imagine just like
with Tyler Murray there's a spot below
which you say okay that's a problem I
think for the Steelers there's a gap
between what other teams are offering
versus a division rival would be
offering or the Patriots where you say
look there's too much of a difference
here we can't say no to this he's Mike
Florio from Pro Football Talk joining a
Stan Patrick show what happens next with
Robert Kraft as owner of the Patriots in
your opinion well this is fascinating
because from his perspective and all we
know from Robert Kraft is he
categorically denies the allegations
hired an attorney to represent him I
mean he may indeed push to proclaim and
prove his innocence in court however
long it takes and the other side of that
is I think the NFL would probably like
this thing to go away sooner rather than
later and the state of the nfo issued
yesterday Dan out of the blue I think
the purpose of that was to make sure
everyone understands the NFL will do
nothing on this case until the criminal
case ends so then you start wondering
what's going on behind the scenes
well the NFL try to broker a deal where
hey if you make this thing go away
quickly and and as quietly as possible
not that quiet as possible at this point
but if it goes away without court
proceedings and a trial and an extended
embarrassment for the league then that
becomes a factor that we will weigh in
your favor when we determine the
discipline and if that's the case you've
got to think back to 2015 because Robert
Kraft then chose not to appeal the
penalties that were imposed on the
Patriots for deflategate chose not to
pursue any of the available litigation
angles he decided you know what we're
going to take it because that's going to
get a better deal for Tom Brady and like
Brady got suspended he was livid because
he claims he was led to believe that if
he did the quote/unquote right thing by
way of the penalties against the
Patriots
would be taken care of so now I want to
trust whatever winking and nodding and
he's going to want it all spelled out if
they approach him with some idea for
making a criminal case go away quickly
and then they won't be as stringent with
the punishment that's that's got to be
something he trusts this time because
based on last time around
he'd have reason to not trust what the
leech says but I wonder as we move
forward because you can pay a fine you
can do community service you can be
suspended but the one thing that you're
never going to be able to erase is the
embarrassment here and you're the owner
of the Patriots what he still want to
have that title given sort of that feel
that's gonna be out there no matter
where he goes is it better for the
Patriots if he would step back or down
and there's a sense that he was in the
process of doing that anyway there's
been a sense at some point he's going to
hand the keys to the car over to
Jonathan craft and have Jonathan craft
run the team just like there was a
century Richardson was going to sell the
team at some point and the thing that
happened in late 2017 people say all the
league forces decided to sell the league
could have forced him to sell the team
and the league can't force Robert Kraft
to take a step back from owning the
Patriots but this is something that
could be part of it and I think the best
solution for the league would be if
Robert Kraft imposes on himself a
sanction that is viewed as fair and and
acceptable to take the Commissioner out
of that hot seat where he's got to worry
about people being mad that he didn't go
far enough
people being mad that he went too far
he's still got all those Patriots fans
that don't like him as a result of the
brady suspension so if crap can lift
this burden off of Goodell and do
something like just you know accelerate
whatever timetable is already in place
to put Jonathan in charge of the team
that seems like it would be a
potentially workable solution and it
wouldn't surprise me if that's the way
that it plays out I'm not saying it well
I mean again all we know at this point
is he categorically denies it and that's
a sign that he plans to fight it and
until we see otherwise we have to assume
he's at least considering the
possibility of fighting do you think
that there is a price that Colin
Kaepernick would accept to play in the
XFL or the
well I've seen the reports that he
requested 20 million dollars and here's
my threshold question is that his bottom
line or was that his opener in response
to the very low pay structure that both
of those leagues have and if their
response was sorry we're not interested
in talking you never get to his bottom
line because you're not going to ask for
20 million as as part of mine he's gonna
say all right
XS are gonna pay quarterbacks 250 a year
hey after paying all your players 250
for 3 years I want 20 million and then
they moved and then you move and they
move in you move and you eventually get
to I don't know 12 million or 10 billion
but whether it's whether it's 10 whether
it's somewhere in between you may be the
argument Israel value their think of how
how differently we would view the AAS if
he was playing for them like here's a
game Sunday night
NFL Network you're gonna watch that game
right now you're like who are these guys
and they're marketing the coaches they
tune in to watch Steve Spurrier and
Dennis Erickson
that's the only names they can give us
at this point dance so I think that
there's an argument to be made that
there's value now I think both leagues
are concerned about going too far with
chasing players and then becoming the
next league that fails because it runs
out of money but III could make the
argument that that he's worth between 10
and 20 million especially because if one
we get sir the other one doesn't have it
and the league that gets him
automatically becomes the more likely
lead to survive thank you my good to
catch up with you again thank you very
much that's a Mike Florio pro football
talk.com for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]